In this video, we'll
add the hour of the day
to our line plot,
and then create
an alternative visualization
using a heat map.
We can do this by creating a
line for each day of the week
and making the x-axis
the hour of the day.
We first need to
create a counts table
for the weekday, and hour.
So we'll use the table function
and give as the first variable,
the Weekday variable
in our data frame.
and as the second variable,
the Hour variable.
This table gives, for each
day of the week and each hour,
the total number of motor
vehicle thefts that occurred.
For example, on
Friday at 4 AM, there
were 473 motor vehicle
thefts, whereas on Saturday
at midnight, there were
2,050 motor vehicle thefts.
Let's save this
table to a data frame
so that we can use it
in our visualizations.
We'll call it DayHourCounts and
use the as.data.frame function,
run on our table, where the
first variable is the Weekday
and the second
variable is the Hour.
Let's take a look at the
structure of the data
frame we just created.
We can see that we have
168 observations-- one
for each day of the
week and hour pair,
and three different variables.
The first variable, Var1,
gives the day of the week.
The second variable, Var2,
gives the hour of the day.
And the third variable,
Freq for frequency,
gives the total crime count.
Let's convert the
second variable, Var2,
to actual numbers
and call it Hour,
since this is the
hour of the day,
and it makes sense
that it's numerical.
So we'll add a new variable to
our data frame called Hour =
as.numeric(as.character(DayHourCounts$Var2)).
This is how we convert a factor
variable to a numeric variable.
Now we're ready to
create our plot.
We just need to change
the group to Var1,
which is the day of the week.
So we'll use the
ggplot function where
our data frame is DayHourCounts,
and then in our aesthetic,
we want the x-axis
to be Hour this time,
the y-axis to be Freq, and
then in the geom_line option,
like we used in
the previous video,
we want the aesthetic to
have the group equal to Var1,
which is the day of the week.
Go ahead and hit Enter.
You should see a new plot show
up in the graphics window.
It has seven lines, one
for each day of the week.
While this is
interesting, we can't
tell which line is which
day, so let's change
the colors of the
lines to correspond
to the days of the week.
To do that, just scroll
up in your R console,
and after group =
Var1, add color = Var1.
This will make the
colors of the lines
correspond to the
day of the week.
After that parenthesis,
go ahead and type comma,
and then size = 2.
We'll make our lines
a little thicker.
Now in our plot, each line
is colored corresponding
to the day of the week.
This helps us see that
on Saturday and Sunday,
for example, the green
and the teal lines,
there's less motor vehicle
thefts in the morning.
While we can get some
information from this plot,
it's still quite
hard to interpret.
Seven lines is a lot.
Let's instead visualize the same
information with a heat map.
To make a heat map,
we'll use our data
in our data frame DayHourCounts.
First, though, we need to
fix the order of the days
so that they'll show up
in chronological order
instead of in
alphabetical order.
We'll do the same thing we
did in the previous video.
So for DayHourCounts$Var1,
which is the day of the week,
we're going to use the factor
function where the first
argument is our variable,
DayHourCounts$Var1,
the second argument
is ordered = TRUE,
and the third argument is
the order we want the days
of the week to show up in.
So we'll set levels,
equals, and then c,
and then list your
days of the week.
Let's put the weekdays first
and the weekends at the end.
So we'll start with Monday,
and then Tuesday, then
Wednesday, then Thursday,
Friday, Saturday and Sunday.
Now let's make our heat map.
We'll use the ggplot
function like we always do,
and give our data frame
name, DayHourCounts.
Then in our aesthetic,
we want the x-axis
to be the hour of the
day, and the y-axis
to be the day of the
week, which is Var1.
Then we're going
to add geom_tile.
This is the function we
use to make a heat map.
And then in the
aesthetic for our tiles,
we want the fill to
be equal to Freq.
This will define the colors of
the rectangles in our heat map
to correspond to
the total crime.
You should see a heat map pop
up in your graphics window.
So how do we read this?
For each hour and
each day of the week,
we have a rectangle
in our heat map.
The color of that rectangle
indicates the frequency,
or the number of crimes
that occur in that hour
and on that day.
Our legend tells us
that lighter colors
correspond to more crime.
So we can see that
a lot of crime
happens around midnight,
particularly on the weekends.
We can change the
label on the legend,
and get rid of the y label to
make our plot a little nicer.
We can do this by just scrolling
up to our previous command
in our R console and then
adding scale_fill_gradient.
This defines properties
of the legend,
and we want name =
"Total MV Thefts",
for total motor vehicle thefts.
Then let's add, in the
theme(axis.title.y =
element_blank()).
This is what you
can do if you want
to get rid of one
of the axis labels.
Go ahead and hit Enter.
And now on our heat
map, the legend
is titled "Total MV Thefts"
and the y-axis label is gone.
We can also change
the color scheme.
We can do this by scrolling
up in our R console,
and going to that
scale_fill_gradient function,
the one that defines
properties of our legend,
and after name =
"Total MV Thefts",
low = "white", high = "red".
We'll make lower
values correspond
to white colors
and higher values
correspond to red colors.
If you hit enter, a
new plot should show up
with different colors.
This is a common color
scheme in policing.
It shows the hot spots, or the
places with more crime, in red.
So now the most crime is
shown by the red spots
and the least crime is
shown by the lighter areas.
It looks like Friday night
is a pretty common time
for motor vehicle thefts.
We saw something that we didn't
really see in the heat map
before.
It's often useful to change
the color scheme depending
on whether you want high
values or low values
to pop out, and the feeling
you want the plot to portray.
In this video, we've seen how to
create some new types of plots.
In the next video, we'll
see how to add data
to geographical maps.